.
CONGRESSMAN BIGGS IS JOINING US
NOW.
HE'S A MEMBER OF THE HOUSE
JUDICIARY AND OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEES.
DID THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAVE
ANY SATISFACTORY ANSWERS FOR
YOUR QUESTIONS, CONGRESSMAN?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT, JON.
IN FACT, HE COULDN'T ADDRESS HOW
MANY ARRESTS, HOW MANY PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN PROSECUTED UNDER OUR
IMMIGRATION LAWS.
HE CAN'T TELL US HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE WANDERING AROUND THE COUNTRY
WITH REMOVAL ORDERS.
HE COULDN'T ANSWER ANYTHING
PERTAINING TO THAT.
BUT SOMEHOW, JON, HE FOUND THE
ABILITY TO PERSONALLY, AS HE
SAID, PERSONALLY WORK ON THAT
MEMORANDUM TO GO AFTER PARENTS
AT SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY INCOMPETENCE,
AND IT'S MORE THAN THAT, IT'S A
DERELICTION OF DUTY IN MY
OPINION.
>> JON: OKAY.
WHY IS THE ADMINISTRATION
WILLING TO COMPLETELY LOOK THE
OTHER WAY AS MORE -- WELL OVER A
MILLION PEOPLE HAVE JUST KIND OF
WALKED INTO OUR COUNTRY?
>> I WILL GIVE YOU TWO TO THREE
REASONS.
NUMBER ONE, THEY CAMPAIGNED ON
AN OPEN BORDER.
NUMBER TWO, THEY SAID THAT
THEY'VE INDICATED THAT THEY
THINK THESE FOLKS WILL END UP
VOTING DEMOCRAT AT SOME POINT,
AND THAT'S PART OF WHY THEY WANT
TO GIVE AMNESTY TO THESE PEOPLE,
WHICH IS ULTIMATELY A PATH TO
CITIZENSHIP.
AND THE THIRD THING IS, THERE'S
A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT ARE IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION THAT DON'T
BELIEVE IN THE [INAUDIBLE]
NATION STATE.
THEY DON'T BELIEVE IN THE
CONCEPT OF A NATION STATE.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN A
TREASURE ON THE LEFT FOR A LONG
TIME TO ELIMINATE THAT.
SO THERE'S THREE REASONS RIGHT
THERE, BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS,
THEY ALL MAKE OUR COUNTRY MORE
INSECURE, AND THIS IS A NATIONAL
SECURITY ISSUE RIGHT NOW.
>> JON: WE WANT TO PUT UP THE
FISCAL YEAR NUMBERS FROM 2020
VERSUS 2021.
FISCAL YEAR ENDED IN SEPTEMBER.
458,000 APPREHENSIONS AT THE
BORDER LAST YEAR.
THIS YEAR, 1 MILLION 734,686.
THOSE ARE JUST THE
APPREHENSIONS.
THERE ARE, WHAT, TENS OF
THOUSANDS, HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
MORE WHO CAME ACROSS THE BORDER
BUT DID NOT GET STOPPED?
>> JON, THAT'S RIGHT.
THE ESTIMATE IS AT LEAST A HALF
A MILLION.
SO WE HAVE KNOWN GOT AWAYS OF
ABOUT A THOUSAND A DAY THAT WE
KNOW ARE GETTING INTO THE
COUNTRY.
THEN THERE'S A WHOLE LOT OF
OTHER PEOPLE WE DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY GET IN.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY ARE
GOING.
COMING FROM.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THEIR
INTENTIONS ARE.
IF THEY'RE NOT SURRENDERING --
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW EVERYBODY IS
SURRENDERING BECAUSE THEY KNOW
THEY WILL BE RELEASED INTO THE
COUNTRY MOST LIKELY.
IF THEY ARE NOT SURRENDERING,
THEY'RE BRINGING PROBABLY DRUGS.
THEY'RE SEX TRAFFICKING.
THEY'RE HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
SOME PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY ON THE
TERRORIST WATCH LIST THAT ARE
COMING INTO OUR COUNTRY.
WHILE I WAS THERE A WEEK AGO,
SITTING IN A MEETING WITH SOME
BORDER PATROL LEADERS, A FELLOW
FROM SYRIA CAME INTO THE COUNTRY
THAT THEY APPREHENDED.
THIS IS A REAL ISSUE, JON.
IT'S WELL OVER 2 MILLION PEOPLE
HAVE COME INTO THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY THIS YEAR.
>> JON: WHERE IS THE VICE
PRESIDENT?
SHE'S THE ONE WHO IS SUPPOSED TO
BE FIXING THIS PROBLEM; RIGHT?
>> WELL, SHE'S SUPPOSED TO BE,
BUT SHE'S TALKING ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE BEING THE ROOT CAUSE.
AND THE ROOT CAUSE -- SHE WOULD
SEE BETTER IF SHE WOULD LOOK IN
THE MIRROR.
IT IS HER AND JOE BIDEN WITH
THEIR HORRIBLE POLICIES AND
THEIR FAILURE TO LEAD ON THIS
ISSUE.
I'M KIND OF GLAD THAT SHE'S NOT
MORE INVOLVED BECAUSE SHE TENDS
TO MESS UP EVERYTHING SHE
TOUCHES.
>> JON: MEANTIME, WE HAVE GOT
THAT HUGE CARAVAN, APPARENTLY
THE LARGEST YET ON ITS WAY FROM
I GUESS THE SOUTHERN PART OF
MEXICO ON ITS WAY UP AND HEADED
FOR THE BORDER.
WHAT IS THE ADMINISTRATION DOING
TO TRY TO TURN THAT AROUND?
>> WELL, AS FAR AS I KNOW,
THEY'RE JUST MONITORING.
I MEAN, WHAT WE NEED IS WE NEED
A VIGOROUS COOPERATIVE
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE MEXICAN
GOVERNMENT IN THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE STATES TO ACTUALLY PUT
DOWN SPEED STICKS FOR THESE
CARAVANS LIKE WE HAD WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WHEN HE GOT INVOLVED AND WORKED
WITH THESE LEADERS, THEY STARTED
HELPING US STOP THOSE CARAVANS.
THESE GUYS ARE DOING NOTHING.
I'VE MET WITH BORDER PATROL
AGENTS AT DIFFERENT SECTORS OVER
THE LAST FEW WEEKS ASKING THEM
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
THEY ARE PUTTING TOGETHER PLANS.
THERE'S VIRTUALLY NOT ENOUGH
PERSONNEL OR FACILITIES TO DEAL
WITH THIS.
WE HAVE TO HAVE HELP FROM THE
MEXICAN GOVERNMENT.
QUITE FRANKLY IT WOULD BE NICE
TO GET SOME HELP FROM OUR
GOVERNMENT LEADERS TOO.
>> JON: REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN
ANDY BIGGS OF ARIZONA, THANK